here we are on overtime does the panel
think that Congress should authorize
Obama's use of force against Isis no I'm
sure I precedent but he does he's he
repeals the previous authority in Iraq
to go and do this it's a more limited
act why can't we let the countries in
the area fight Isis it's it's it's it's
their fight as long as we're in there
aren't we always giving them some reason
not to hate each other but they needed
to do there's no question but you
already the president has a greater
authority now this actually limits his
authority when you take a look he's said
that were not that long ago that Isis
was not a threat to our national
security here's the irony they're suing
the president for usurping this
authority that the Boehner has got a
suit against him and they've given up
their power to earmark them and now they
don't even want to vote on the board
they're just gonna let him go ahead with
it the Congress ought to get involving
and voted up or down but Congress ought
to get involved they have a
constitutional responsibility to do that
I'm gonna agree with the representative
on this if we're gonna fight we should
definitely should do it through Congress
and and put their names on the record
names on I am NOT not really not really
I don't think Isis is a threat to us
here at home I think they're doing some
horrible things and I think there's a
lot we can do to help reduce that but I
think our 15 years of war in the Middle
East haven't done very much in fact it's
probably created by Isis and I know you
know
I think I give you I think you give you
stand behind the President on this he's
going on a limb on this kind of thing it
may be a Democratic president but I
think you give him the authority and
hope he carries out better than the
authority we gave Bush well it went
sideways rangerous I know but it went
sideways yes it sure did well I mean Jeb
running for president says Bush was a
great president he's gotta say yeah
you're gonna run real one guy he's the
one guy who was allowed to own George
Bush because everybody would say if he
did the opposite wow I can't even stick
up for his brother exactly exactly
Dave what can you tell us about the
rumors of an x-files reboot from from
that to that III think it looks good I
think it looks good very good
Oh
[Applause]
as a TV show as a limited run television
so a limited run limit how many shows
would uh I don't know exactly but it'd
be limited less than infinite so after
all these years that [ __ ] is still out
there yeah
I'm just as surprised as you
it's just like political Quran I thought
we got rid of it in the night I also
does not believe in conspiracies like
you like you yeah I do not I believe
it's very difficult for two people to
keep a secret right a third person I
agree let alone killing Kennedy right
yeah it's not gonna happen but we love a
conspiracy we have a hundred thousand
with scientists all over the world that
are creating a conspiracy saying there's
really climate change they've yes all
get together does the closure of the US
Embassy in Yemen signal another foreign
policy defeat for Obama I don't think so
I think it signals a rational move in a
country that's just collapsed although
he did cite it as a success just a
couple months ago well and the country
collapse earlier you said you know no
national interest with ISIL then you go
it's Yemen yeah who cares about Yemen I
assume you're thinking no I'm not sure
you're reading my mind what I'm saying
is it's Yemen bad [ __ ] always happens so
at what point in that part of the world
it does is there any point at which
complete instability kind of murderous
caliphates causes you to think that the
US has an interest in that part of the
world well they have we have an interest
but it's how best to serve that interest
I think the best way to serve that
interest is to stop being helicopter
parents for the Muslim people who have
to have a civil war the ISIS is
surrounded by strong countries all have
avowed interest in fighting Isis why
can't Saudi Arabia Egypt Turkey Iran all
these countries why can't they do it why
do we have to do everything
why do we have to be the guardians of
the galaxy and as long as we're always
in there it gives them a common enemy so
they never have to face their real
problems well they are actually going
together with you it wasn't just the
u.s. right now it's a branch broader
coalition and I submit that the u.s. is
the country which has the military
capacity to deal with these kind of
things to think about how to I'm not
suggesting the US has to go in with
people on the ground but it was right
that we become like the invaders we
bring them we bring them together on
that that's yeah but it's the same
there's an analogous argument actually
going on in Europe now there's a nice
argument where you know the u.s. the
Putin's move westwards the Ukraine
crisis is again a situation you know
should the u.s. be involved what would
you think that no no so the Western
alliance doesn't mean it it means
something but we never used to do this
we never used to think we had to go
every single place where there was
trouble in the world all through the
Cold War I think there was a huge amount
of that there was a lot of proxy wars
where the u.s. went in and where the
u.s. supported people in the during the
Cold War I would know that was a great
idea huh was that a great idea Vietnam
Vietnam was not a great well that was
the proxy war of which you speak oh
there was Nicaragua all those kind of
another great success if you if you are
you going to a world where the US turns
in and says we no longer think we have
circular international but there's
something in between complete
isolationism and getting involved every
place in the world you like maybe it
comes down to what the word involved
actually means I think what we did in
Iraq wrong country hundred thousand
troops trillions of dollars was an
absolute mistake how we slice and dice
this Isis thing maybe we're just sending
drones and it's a robot war that's what
we're doing the Iraq war was a good idea
would you agree with Kuwait I think it's
oh it was a very selective use of moral
superior where it's like all our nation
got invaded we should intervene we don't
do that universe we had a much broader
coalition behind us there we're picky
when our oil is at stake and it seems to
matter a bit
but yeah it was Elizab stronger case for
that one than the post 9/11 boondoggle
okay with gay marriage is now legal
Alabama do you think we will see any
conservative politicians reversing their
stance on gay rights I think the court
is going to take it out of the political
area courtly I think that's and they'll
all be happy about that right they don't
really want that one on their table any
pulled politically it's probably an
advantage to get that off the table for
Republicans Robertson's the release of
food Inc have you seen any positive
changes in the regulation of our food
industry yeah I think that first of all
I think the public has become very much
more conscious of what they're eating
perhaps due to shows like yours as well
so people are much more you know
concerned and there have been some
regulations though there's still all the
antibiotics out there and I see this
week eggs are okay again yeah we never
stop eating them yeah I never did either
because I was saying that last week
they'd love to demonize [ __ ] well
cholesterol we got to get stay out of
the Sun and get a cholesterol eat
pasture Dex d-twah eat eggs that are
like from chickens that are walking
around out on the grass so you're gonna
eat good eggs and they're gonna be
healthy okay all right thank you
everybody thank you audience we got a
few other
[Applause]